هدير عاطف بلوجر مصري بيتابعها الملايين
صحيح لكن فيكتور ما كانوا بيعرفوها قبل ما
يتصدر اسمها التراند والعناوين اليوم هدير
عندها حساب على انستغرام بيتابعها عليه
مليونين ونصف شخص وبتعرف عن وبتعرف عن
حالها في بانها بلوجر موضه ولايف ستايل
وسفر امبارح بالليل وفجاه انتشر فيديو
بشكل واسع للوالده هدير عم تستفيد وتصيح
وبتناشد الجهات المعنيه والناس بانقاب
بنتها اللي بحسب كلامها خطفها بلطجيه
انا بنتي من الساعه 7:00 انا بلاش سياده
الرئيس وبلاش اللي النائب العام وانا
شايفكم كلكم سايبه بنت دخلوا علينا بلطجيه
هاتها واخذوا فلوسها واخذوا كل حاجه
وسابني في القلب
وعندها مشاكل
سموها وخدوا ابنتي الساعه 7:00 الصبح لحد
دلوقت انت مش عارفه فين مش عارفه كده في
الشارع
[موسيقى]
حب عمري
كله اخذ ذهب واخذ الفلوس وخدوا كل حاجه هي
اجزتها الوحيده اللي هي اتجوزت واحد وحش
احنا من مشترك فلوس في واحد وحش وواحد وحش
بيشتغل في اي حاجه خذوا بنتي وحققوا معه
لو لقيته على حاجه تستاهل يجرب بنتي ما
عليهاش
حاجه تطلقت منه قبرته عن كل حاجه
[موسيقى]
مع فيديو الام والاستغاثه هذه طلع زوجها
لهدير بلال ذيب قلب الدنيا بستوريات فيها
كلام مش مفهوم عن عقود وفلوس واقسم شرطه
وفي لستوريات كمان هدد بالانتحار وقال
كمان عشر دقائق مش راح مش هاكون موجود في
الحياه وانا لله وانا اليه راجعون وكاتب
حسبي الله ونعم الوكيل كذا مره وكلام كثير
ثاني فعليه مش مفهوم وقال كمان بلال الحق
وهدير وهدير قائله في رقبتكم وانه ما
اعرفش او ما بعرف هدير وين ولا بنته هايله
البنت طبعا اللي شفناها قبل شويه في
الفيديو ومع ام هدير تفصيلتين اخرى يا
ريتان عن بلال مشاهدينا قبل ما احكي لكم
الكوبرا في القصه اولا
حسابوا عليه 300,000 وشويه تحول من عام
الى حساب خاص ومسكر قدام اللي ما بتابعهم
ثانيا
اواخر الشهر الماضي اع متلقاكم وهدير حتى
نصعد كل صورهم من حسابها هاي تفصيله مهمه
كثير لما تسمعوا بقيه القصه فمن بعد اللي
كل اللي سمعتوه وشفتوه والكلام عن اختفاء
واختطاف وانتحار وفلوس المفاجاه صادمه
كانت اعلان السلطات بالقبض على هدير
والتهمه النصب بين داخليه ما قال اسمها
صراحه لكنه قال بلوجر ازياء والناس
والاعلام استنتجوا انها هدير بيان
الداخليه قال انها تلقت بلاغات من 16
مواطن ضد البلوجر وزوجها وشقيقته وزوجها
بتتهمهم بالنصب والاحتيال عليه والتحصل
على مبالغ
ماليهم بيملكوا مجموعه شركات تعمل في مجال
العقارات والسيارات والتداول المالي
وقالوا لهم انه راح يستثمرونهم الفلوس
مقابل ارباح نتيجه وقال بيان الداخليه انه
البلوجر حتى هو جاءت على حسابها على
انستغرام
وداخليه اعلنت القبض على ثلاثه من
المتهمين الاربعه اللي اعترفوا بتلقي
اموال من المجني عليهم قلتها اكثر من
مليون جنيه بحجه استثمارها مقابل ارباح
لكنهم لا قدموا ارباح ولا ردوا للناس اصل
المبلغ اصلا وختمه الداخليه بيانها بانها
تم اتخاذ الاجراءات القانونيه والصوره
اللي نشرتها الداخليه ومع انها مش واضحه
كثير ومش مبينه والوجوه تحديدا لكن واضح
انه فيها سيدتين ورجل وناس قالوا اكيد
هدير وحده منهم اما هل الرجل في الصوره
وزوجها او زوج اخته فهذا مش معروفه بيان
داخليه ايضا اكتفى بالتاكيد انه الجهود
مستمره للقبض على المتهم الهارب من دون
توضيح هويته وهون لافته ونذكر انه يعني
داخليه قلب بلوجر ازياء وزوجها بينما
مثلنا هم اعلنوا من فتره طلائهم الموضوع
الثاني اللي الناس كثير انتبهت له وهو انه
صور هدير على انستقرام ومن اسابيع في
كومنتات بتتكرروا من حسابات مختلفه بتقول
لها رجعي فلوسنا وبتوصفها بالنصاب كمان